Suggested taking coconut oil for braid issues. Was that liquid or solid?
So coconut oil could be extremely beneficial for braid issues too because the braid is made up of fats, right?
So you need good fats. It's really important to have good fats.
That, in fact, I used... I liked telling this one story years and years ago
when I was in... I was thinking I was doing clinicals at the time.
So this was a long time ago.
There was a baby that was brought in to clinicals that had what was called at that time,
Loppy Baby Syndrome. That was actually a disease in the medical system's mind.
Loppy Baby Syndrome. This baby could sit up and I think it was...
I can't remember the details, but this baby was well, you know, a year later that this person,
this baby should have been sitting up and their parents would sit him up and he'd just literally fall over.
He'd just literally fall over. He was happy, nothing like that.
He had no tone, no muscle tone.
And all we did is give him coconut oil.
So we gave him coconut... We gave him fish oil at the time.
And literally the next visit, which was the next week, he was crawling.
So it was like unbelievable transformation and it was suggested because what the time were,
they were on some low... This was the low fat diet was really big and the bomb was breastfeeding,
but she was on this low fat diet because she wanted to lose her baby fat and so this baby was getting
no fats and so you need that.
So, sorry, but your question was coconut oil.
Should I be taking that as a liquid or a solid?
So you could just buy a tub of organic coconut oil at Costco and or your grocery store just get organic coconut oil
and if it liquefies because your house is really warm, you know, then that's fine.
Usually it's stable to 100 and some degrees, but otherwise it's going to be like a...
it's going to look like a crisco or something.
So you just want to take a table spoon of that and go put down.
And this person's referring to a study that was out a number of years ago where they actually took...
I can't remember how many... I think it was like 30 patients that had dementia.
And in order to diagnose dementia, there was a little memory test that they had to take.
And they were, you know, graded on that memory test.
And for 30 days, they took... I can't remember.
Two or three table spoons of coconut oil.
That was all they did.
And they were separated into a couple groups.
I think 30 were in the test group that were taking the coconut oil.
All 30 of them scored higher on their test.
All of them did just by taking coconut oil.
So it just tells you the need for fat to the brain.
When you're not... these low fat diets and stuff, it's just very damaging to your immune system.
It's very damaging to your neural function and it's not good for you.
So getting good fat in your brain can be extremely helpful.
You can see... you can see a turnaround in things quickly.